THE STATE OF VOX:
At first glance, Vox is an extraordinarily
successful media organization.
On YouTube alone, they have 11 million subscribers
and over 3 billion views.
And in the last 30 days itself, they’ve
gained over 20 million views and a hundred
thousand subscribers.
Given the high quality journalism and documentaries
that come out of Vox, it’s not surprising
that they’re so successful.
But, what may be surprising is that there’s
a large community that can’t stand Vox.
They believe that Vox skews perspectives and
that much of their content centers around
garnering attention as opposed to truly informing.
It’s not just some viewers that are put
off by their content either, many journalists
are as well.
Just one Google seach will bring up dozens
of opinion pieces trashing on Vox.
But, much of this, you can just write off
as natural criticism.
Whenever an organization gets relatively large,
its gonna attract detracters regardless of
what they do.
But, something that we can’t write off as
simply is the exodus at Vox.
Johnny Harris, is likely the most notable
example, but he’s by no means the only one.
Another Vox journalist turned YouTuber is
Cleo Abram.
It’s not just journalists who are leaving
Vox either.
This exodus actually goes all the way to the
top.
In just the last few years, 2 out of the 3
Vox founders left the company.
And it’s not like these guys completely
quit journalism or the media industry either.
They just quit Vox.
Matthew Yglesias, for example, left so that
he could become a writer at a paid newsletter
called Substack.
Similarly, Ezra Klein left Vox to become a
notable journalist at the New York Times.
Yet another executive who ditched Vox is Laruen
Williams.
While she wasn’t a cofounder, she did serve
as editor in chief and senior vice president.
Too make things worse, all three of these
departures happened in the same month, November
of 2020.
There’s also a good chance that Vox is dealing
with some financial challenges throughout
this recession given that they laid of 39
people last year.
So, what happened to Vox?
DARING BEGINNINGS:
Taking a look back, Ezra Klein wasn’t always
looking to ditch Vox.
In fact, not too long ago, he was looking
to ditch the Washington Post.
Ezra was the head of a public policy blog
where he regularly analyzed and discussed
upcoming legislation and the political landscape.
While this was a pretty safe position to be
in, Ezra felt the need to address a shortfall
within the market.
He felt that the traditional media outlets
weren’t providing in ea to upper management.
But, after they rejected his idea, it didn’t
take him long to leave, and he took several
Washington Post employees with him including
one of Vox’s other co founders: Melissa
Bell.
Together, they hired a team of 20 people each
of whom were an expert in a given topic area,
and shortly after, they launched Vox on April
6, 2014 with the goal of making the news exciting
again.
Their initial content focused on explaining
various facets of the Affordable Care Act
or Obamacare.
They also spent time exploring economic issues
like the massive public debt.
These articles and videos performed quite
well especially for a brand new media organization.
But, it would take Vox a few months to really
trigger the algorithm which brings us to their
first viral hit: Three big reasons war is
going away.
They followed this up with yet another viral
hit just a few weeks later titled “Weed
is not more dangerous than alcohol”.
Pretty quickly, Vox started to build a name
for themselves as the edgy media outlet that
wasn’t afraid to make their positions clear.
I mean, they were literally claiming that
the US debt wasn’t a big deal and that weed
shouldn’t be ostracized.
They even had videos comparing Bitcoin to
the internet and debunking Shark Week.
While many of these were great one off videos,
Vox was yet to find a core series that people
would tune in for.
But, this would change on July 23, 2014 when
Vox posted a video called “What made North
Korea so bizarre”.
Vice had already popularized the elusive nature
of North Korea across YouTube.
So when Vox posted a video about North Korea,
it instantly went viral, and since then, North
Korea based content has become a staple on
the channel garnering tens of millions of
views.
It looks like this is one of the things that
Johnny Harris took with him from Vox as he
has his own multi million view North Korea
video.
Speaking of Johnny Harris, he was an early
employee at Vox having joined in 2014 as a
senior video producer.
Aside from producing videos about North Korea,
Johnny worked on producing map based videos,
something that he’s since become known for.
Eventually, Johnny would merge the elusive
aspect of North Korea with the geographical
aspect of maps.
And the combination of these two sides would
lead to the creation of one of Vox’ most
popular docu series of all time: Borders which
brings us into the glory days of Vox.
THE GLORY DAYS:
In the late 2010s, Vox was killing it.
If you go to their channel and sort by most
popular, you’ll see that virtually all of
their most popular videos were posted during
this time period.
Not only did they have deep thought provoking
content about various hot topics, but they
delivered said content in an exceptional way.
This is something that hasn’t changed at
Vox to this day.
The quality of their animations, infographics,
and editing is top notch for YouTube, and
honestly its better than even most traditional
media outlets.
You could say that Vox had achieved their
goal of making informative videos not just
watchable or informative but full on entertaining.
With every video, there was a beginning, middle,
and end with main characters, failures, and
successes.
Each video was a story, a journey through
a specific topic or historical event.
Something that made Vox even more popular
was the downfall of the cable TV.
More and more people were switching completely
streaming platforms like Netflix and Hulu.
But, while these platforms had super exciting
shows and long form documentaries, something
that they lacked was news based content.
And all of this combined led to the extraordinary
rise of what we all know as Vox today.
But, wait a minute.
Where’s the bad stuff?
If Vox was producing such great content, why
do a large portion of viewers and journalists
hate Vox?
And why are leading hosts and even founders
leaving the company?
Well, so far, I’ve only been telling one
side of Vox’s story.
Throughout this entire journey, Vox had another
side that was not nearly as respected.
And I think the best way to explain this other
side is as the BuzzFeed side.
If you’re not familiar with BuzzFeed, they’re
another popular media company that gained
much of their fame during the same time period
as Vox.
Instead of focusing on news based content
though, BuzzFeed focused on entertainment
and experiences, and they were infamous for
their clickbait BS articles.
Here’s a few just to give you an idea.
I Cannot Believe The Haircut Grimes Just Gave
Her And Elon Musk's Baby.
10 Signs That Your Cat Is A Wizard.
Which Ousted Arab Spring Ruler Are You?
Given that Vox was in a much more serious
informative niche, you would think that they
would be above such articles, but they weren’t.
Who is Solange?
And why is she attacking Jay Z?
Jay-Z called lacrosse "soft."
The research literature disagrees.
The time when hip-hop's top drag queen met
RuPaul.
In many of these cases, the writers knew that
the articles were ridiculous.
But, they posted them anyway because they
also knew that they could leverage these celebrities
and their drama.
While these articles may have gotten clicks,
they took away from Vox’s credibility as
the informative and reputable digital media
source.
In the grand scheme of things though, this
was the smallest of their offenses.
The real critic of Vox is that they tell one
sided stories.
ONE SIDED:
I didn’t want to make this video political,
but that’s impossible to achieve when Vox
themselves is so political.
Basically every video they post seemingly
has an underlying liberal agenda, and this
dates back to their very first videos.
How Obamacare will change health insurance
forever.
Competent women are getting bypassed by overconfident
men.
Weed is not more dangerous than alcohol.
I’m not suggesting that any of these stances
are right or wrong, but simply that they only
cover one side of the story.
This doesn’t just stop at the headlines
or thumbnails either.
Basically every word, every sentence in the
video is carefully concocted to make you think
a certain way.
When in reality, real journalism should focus
on providing an objective view of all sides.
I mean, this is one of the biggest problems
with traditional media as well.
You’ve got your liberal outlets like CNN,
The New York Times, and NBC, and you’ve
got your conservative outlets like Fox, The
New York Post, and Newsmax.
Given that one of Vox’s goals was to make
up for the shortfalls legacy media, you would
think that they would’ve spent a lot of
effort in gathering on conveying diverse viewpoints.
But, instead, it seems like Vox has simply
become a traditional media outlet that’s
good at social media and the internet.
But, despite the new medium, Vox has all of
the same issues as traditional media.
And, it’s not just liberal viewpoints that
they support either.
They even go as far as defending people from
the left.
One of the best examples of this is with a
journalist named Sarah Jeong.
In 2019, Sarah made the following remarks
on Twitter.
“Oh man it’s kind of sick how much joy
I get out of being cruel to old white men”
“White people marking up the internet with
their opinions like dogs pissing on fire hydrants”
and “#CancelWhitePeople.”
Vox published not one but three separate articles
defending Sarah.
They even went as far as categorizing Sarah’s
comments as “the expressive way anti-racists
and minorities talk about white people”
and the arguments from the other side as “a
major bullying tactic of the alt-right”.
I don’t think anything else needs to be
said about this situation.
Over the years, these types of situations
have simply increased in popularity leading
to much of the distaste surrounding Vox.
“It's incredibly ironic that "Vox" is Latin
for Voice, yet they are actively involved
in the censorship and deplatforming of people
and groups they dislike..”
“If I see they're the source, then I always
backcheck the information.
Not a source that I'd link to other people
as being reliable.
Not to say everything is wrong, just more
likely to be twisted in some way.”
“Their gimmick is claiming to be objective
"explainers" of the news, but in fact they
give it a strong leftward spin.”
And this seems to be the primary issue with
Vox.
THE PARADOX OF VOX:
In the end, Vox started off as an ambitious
startup that was looking to achieve something
that traditional media couldn’t.
This meant conveying seemingly boring topics
in a fun and intuitive manner while maintaining
objectivity and clarity.
But, instead it seems that Vox has fallen
into the same trap as traditional media.
They ended up choosing one side and going
deeper and deeper.
At this point, they’re so far to one side
that they believe that centrism is actually
the media’s biggest bias.
And I think this one reddit comment describes
the situation the best.
“Its pseudo-news.
Yes it conveys facts and explains current
events, but it does so with a bias and they
often cherry pick evidence.
Good entertainment, but not something you
should watch if you're genuinely trying to
inform yourself on a topic.”
And that’s what happened to Vox.
I do gotta say, despite their shortfalls,
their production quality is still insane,
so respect there.
Anyway, are you guys fans of Vox?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you would like to see
a truly objective news organization.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.